[Music]
josh is in tampa florida josh welcome to
the ramsay show
hey thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can i help you
yeah so my wife and i of ten years um
we've been going through counseling and
we've been trying to save our marriage
but
we decided um it was best that we get a
divorce at the end of this year i'm
sorry to hear that so
yeah um yeah we
we tried a lot and
now i'm really just kind of looking
forward and seeing
you know what would you guys do if you
woke up in my shoes so
um i have a i have some cash saved and
there will be additional cash once we
sell our home that we own together in
equity
so that'll be approximately 180 000.
so my my question is if you woke up in
my shoes
and you had 180 000
um
what would you
what would you do i'm kind of torn
between trying to buy a house cash
and or trying to
invest in more passive income
whether that be real estate or
a business venture
well john i'm trying to just make the
best decision yeah i totally understand
that and i'm so sorry to hear what
you've gone through and
it's easy to be in your shoes and get
there because i've been there
and i know what it's like to to deal
with the aftermath of a of a broken
marriage obviously 10 years a long time
and i want i care more about josh right
now than i do about josh's money
it sounds like you're in a fine place
financially but i you need to grieve
this
you need to just take a pause take a
breath there's no urgency around this
the money's gonna be there tomorrow
three months from now six months from
now
so i want you to take a breather and
maybe you get counseling on your own to
grieve and heal and do whatever you need
to do to get josh well
and then we can deal with the money
okay how are you doing
i'm good
okay are there kids involved what's the
ramifications of all this
one kid okay
well is everything finalized
no not yet okay
i would let the the dust settle here um
finalize everything and once you have
this pile of money i want you to just
wait
and get some wise counsel
get some people in your corner maybe get
a tax pro
a real estate pro if you're if you're
wanting to get into that later on make
sure you have a financial advisor who's
helping guide this money it sounds like
you've got a good head on your shoulders
on what to do with it
i would put it towards your next goal
you know filter it through the framework
of the baby steps it sounds like you're
debt-free
um
more or less there's like 3 000 i owe in
a car
and i don't have any credit card debt or
student loan debt okay do you have an
emergency fund in place
yeah yeah i i have
about forty thousand like eighty
thousand total sales and wow passive
passes in a brokerage account and the
other half is in a
bank account i would i would cash out
that brokerage account i'll get out of
that uh
debt pay that thing off become
completely debt free park that three to
six months of emergency i'd probably
lean towards six months in your
situation going through what you're
going through um are you investing
fifteen percent after that
yeah yeah and i i have like a hundred
and seventy thousand of my 401k so
it's like i'm good with retirement okay
so you're on track for a solid
retirement i would get rid of this debt
and just live a debt-free lifestyle
that's going to take away you already
have enough stress and and drama here
and that debt is just going to add to it
so get out of debt never look back
have that emergency fund look forward to
whatever that house purchase may be down
the road and i would use that money
towards that i wouldn't get into real
estate investing or anything
shiny right now
i would focus it on whatever your next
primary residence is use that as a giant
down payment
aside from your emergency fund while
investing and
i don't know what the financials look
like
with the child in the mix and child
support and custody and all that i'm
sure you're still working some of that
out
but i would put it towards that primary
residence and try to get that paid off
and then we can focus on if you want to
do some real estate investing down the
road when you're in baby step seven
that's a fine choice to make
okay all right thank you absolutely josh
i'm so so sorry for what you're going
through man divorce is
so difficult and emotionally taxing
physically taxing financially taxing and
so take your time with this
there's no rush
you're in a good place financially
you've got a big pile of money so just
take care of josh right now and the
money part will take care of itself
later on